let's end this gangbuster of an episode
with a trailer because you know me and
disney plus i have nothing but great
things to say
there is a documentary about
fouchy
um
when the obama's got a netflix deal and
now that um harry and megan have one
um
it is becoming quite clear
that politicians
are
going to
no longer rely on the hacks
in hollywood and the media to portray
them in a uh flattering light they are
going to directly get involved with how
their legacies are sculpted it's a
pretty brilliant move uh these people
are directly going to get involved and
influence
public opinion so there is now a
documentary about fouchy now whatever
you think of fouchy
running the gamut from
aids hitler
to
second coming of of vaccine christ
whatever you think about facts uh fouchy
whatever you think about fouchy
this is wildly unnecessary
we are still in the middle of a pandemic
the resources devoted to making this
film should not have been let's watch
the trailer okay
when i think about my dad growing up i
certainly think about that seriousness
but very few people get to see
he's funny weird and really playful
god help us
in 1981 hiv aids was evolving rapidly
and frighteningly there was anger at the
government's response when you got sick
you were gone fast
it's affecting you now yeah
why i think he was good i think you know
from what i've heard about
him
on the
aids front i believe he was in a don't
you know people are going to be like he
created it
you're a liar and i just
i but what i've heard from people that
work
in epidemiology is that he was good on
that he's been a little bit of a klutz
here
if if if we want to be
really nice about it you'd call him a
klutz
um you if you wanted to be a meanie you
would call him a liar
and um
someone who
has perhaps twisted the truth to protect
people
um but
klutz would would certainly be not wrong
to call him but let's continue this
stress center
he also loves the spotlight he became
this target my dad said we're gonna get
through this whole thing
you do it because you care when you're
involved in a race to stop a horrible
disease
you always feel you're not doing things
quickly enough
[Music]
okay was morbid
it kind of just shows that he kind of
failed like massively well what was he
supposed to do you know completely like
stop aids of course
he's not supposed to do that
um
you know i mean
i guess if you work in that business
like you're always going to kind of fail
right
you know
you know
he's an interesting guy he's been a
government
he's been the the pandemic guy forever
that's a weird dude
you know
the guy who's like you know what gets me
up in the morning what disease you go
okay
stopping it or what
it's like the people that talk about
poverty all the time like do you really
want it to end then what would you do
i work at the center for global poverty
okay and what would you like well we'd
like more global poverty why well that's
kind of what we do
okay
it's kind of with disease a little bit
yeah yeah like we don't want to get rid
of all the diseases
he's like we like to you know
we like a little bit of disease a little
bit
makes everything work see that'd be
funny why doesn't disney do that like do
an animated thing without you is like
having a little fun with gain of
function research you know he's like a
little bit
makes everything work we need just
needles like in the background why can't
we have a little fun where are the
talented people behind uh these pictures
we can do something with little music
you know laura who opened for me in
boston works at harvard and loves
vouching so i know that there's people
that love him
and my problem with him is that he's an
italian an italian and i believe that we
should be represented by an asian or a
jew in the medical field or a pakistani
or someone from india i don't trust a
guy that looks like me talking about
health and i certainly don't trust a mr
meatball
but go check that out for yourself what
are they called disney plus what is it
called it's disney plus it's just called
fauci they were shooting a dock this
this whole time i didn't know that
they're like the when we see jake paul
out and about and there's cameras
following him fouchy had the same thing
but
fouchy is he's epidemiology's jake paul
that's what he is
fouchy is epidemiology's jake paul
you can hate him you can love him but he
ain't going nowhere
that's what it is
you could hate him you could love him
but that man is determined to have his
face
splashed you
there's a virgin of foundation that goes
no i don't want to do this
there's a version of him that goes
i'm busy
there's a version of him that goes i
don't think it's appropriate in the
middle of a pandemic that was supposedly
serious enough where we had to
decimate our entire economy i think it
would be odd
to do like a puff piece on me
why don't we wait a few years
but i guess not you just dove right in
he goes here what time you're gonna be
there nine
should i be in makeup i'll be in makeup
already
don't worry about it he's on the phone
he's like cancel the lab i got a thing
now i got all day it's just the crew
showing up they're like we'll be quick
he's like no no we i blocked off a week
for this they go
really
he goes yeah he goes i'm doing two dope
queens later but right now i have all
the time to talk to you
i'm doing my favorite murder later i'm
gonna tell karen kolgariff about the
vaccine
enough with him